I'm really honored to be here and thanks
for having me all of you I was going to
jump right in and so ocarina just to
kind of quick background alfredo this is
a as a retrospective i admittedly think
you know if you just look at on paper
there's only been eight years this is
not like a you know some seminal paper
that was written like 10 years 20 years
ago this isn't it this is an app it's a
toy made for your phone eight years ago
and but uh and this is really coincided
with you know kinda the founding of
smooth but i will say in the world of
mobile eight years is like forever so a
lot of things many things have evolved
happened since and in some ways actually
i look to things like the R&A are kind
of as an asst perhaps similar tipping
converge of being on the tipping point
as mobile was maybe eight nine years ago
so and of course this coincided with
kind of the you know kind of uh well the
app store and the hat based the
beginning kind of all windows app based
computing with the iphone and then the
App Store not which basically opened
that summer the same summer this mule
was that started and also there's a
follow-up operator to and I'm just going
to give you a quick demo of this right
now just just so you know what I'm
talking about so so I'll kamina is just
is a little a flute-like instrument some
of you may know if from playing legend
of zelda ocarina of time this one does
not transport you in teleports you in
time or space but hopefully it will
transport you musically but probably not
the way I'm playing it
so you blow into this and there's
actually a little program here that's
tracking how pardon blow into this
that's mapped into the articulation of
the sound which is synthesized using
multi-touch to control the pitch and
then vibrato okay so and you can play
little their titties on this so this
little chakra in game mode we're just
kind of telling you what to play next
and it's kind of like ocarina hero of
sorts in that it's kind of advising you
to play but unlike guitar hero rock band
it waits for you so you can you can just
kind of play it at your own pace and
this is by design and still going here I
can have a fairly dramatic entrance
[Music]
and you can see me tilting the phone
down words to express the ends of longer
nodes I always like ending on that cord
because it's kind of pretty so let's do
that so that's that's in a nutshell like
the instrument part of Audrina um and
and there's another side to all trainers
which I will get to but I've kind of
I've given talks with ocarina in it
quite a few more than probably I ever
should so but this one I've taken the
ill-advised route of constructing an
entirely new talk which is probably like
the worst thing I could have done but
it's it would look familiar but I think
will feel different it's a different
aesthetic of a karina talk if you will
so I broken authoring down from
different angles the first one is kind
of as an artifact artful design and and
this is I would say this is both the
subject the book I'm writing but also I
think as a retro part of a retrospective
this is kind of thinking back on what
I'll Karina was was about and perhaps
more than I was able to articulate
definitely more than i was able
articulate at the time then i can now go
back and think about this and the other
thing else says a lot of design is
perhaps post rationalization and which
is saying oh i meant to do this because
it's a was cool and i was like trying to
dress this and i will try to do my best
to kind of give you kind of an honest of
you what was was i thinking at the time
and what was poached rationalization
like out yeah and then to do that when
in fact I'm I don't know if I did or not
um so powerful design and I think this
is really kind of a wrinkling and a
shaping of technology for some purpose
in this case I would say if there is a
practical purpose is to play music with
it stood sound and articulate notes with
discrete pitch and and so and this kind
of falls into my kind of definition
with design which is the first part of
which is some intention shaping of our
world for any practical purpose
practical purpose of you know design and
some of the things is kind of the
formalization formalized intent some
people articulated as the articulation
of preference and I agree with all of
those and I think that's you know this
is designed but also to me design also
have the second component which is doing
this shaping of technology with this
extreme emphasis on aesthetics and I by
aesthetics I don't mean like the Polish
you put on it I mean the very meaning of
the thing you're building and what it
how it feels for someone to actually
engage with the thing you're using and
as you can imagine this has everything
to do with the interaction between
humans and computers and I always think
the more kind of concrete terms no pun
intended to architectural design where
there is this undeniable attention both
to function but that is what you're
going to use the building for and form
the aesthetics and if we were just
purely functional beings our buildings
probably wouldn't would all be like
amorphis blobs that are just the right
size for us to do whatever in but
instead we have buildings of all shapes
and sizes that have different meanings
to the people that different sense of
space different context and difference
you know context in the city and in the
region of fine self in its it's so in
this this case this is a this is the
people's building those of you who read
Chinese might be inspired to read this
as a what Chinese character gen so this
is the Chinese character for people or
human all right so and this is
constructed literally this building's
design as kind of two halves than meet
in the middle right and this was just so
far just a design that I think they're
actually building this in Shanghai but
this is presented in the 2010 world expo
in shanghai and designed by a european
firm and they didn't realize that we're
actually doing
designing this character until they got
to Shanghai and inching how like dude
this is like best thing we gotta wonder
building this and they're like yeah we
meant to do that but they this is
uncanny and and but also if you look at
kind of the functional breakdown of this
one side jets out from the water on one
side from the land and one side mean
it's supposed to smell lies kind of
spiritual body you know kind of and they
meet in the middle in this one thousand
room hotel but you can see all the
functional parts of this but clearly
this has a form anaesthetic to that that
is meaningful i would say that many
different levels and so we'll go back
this idea of design that i think a third
thing about designs that it's think
helpful i think of design as being as
taking place within a medium and you
know whether it's concrete or whether
it's software i think that's you know
its design needs mediums and it worked
borrow kind of this this character and
as always always think of this is one of
my favorite characters in chinese
because it's one simple to write the to
attract that is here and that's its
people and order for us to survive
perhaps thrive we we need to lean
against each other its to have leaning
on the other and I think of designed in
the similar fashion is that there's
these two components wanting my
think of us the pragmatics like what it
does what is meant to do and also
statics which is how it does it and I
think of aesthetics is basically how we
do something how we live go about our
lives or assist etics is the things that
make life more than worth living it's
winning riches life so I think these are
the two sides of design to me that
cannot be divorced from each other and
if we would take one side away you will
not have design so in some ways I think
I'll kareena is kind of a type of person
micrel architectural design and that's
in some ways how I think about this and
if we actually take a closer look at
this whoops I can actually plug in the
sound
start that over
[Music]
same piece that I played and kind of see
also how the instrument visually
responds and I'll see kind of the game
aspect the four holes that is dropping
down its kind of Q is to wait to play
next but it says nothing about how fast
the tempo you suppose he played is that
and leave all that to you and also the
accompaniment that you here is actually
following you so it's it's really kind
of meant to be a very freeform free time
experience but then there's of course
this other dimension to it to ocarina
which is kind of a social experiment a
small one but one that it was kind of
trying to it when it's designing an
ocarina I know that this i can say that
was what i was thinking about was it I
wanted to do something with I'll kareena
and on the medium it's in IE you know
kind of this on the iphone um and do at
least one thing that you can't do with
like a traditional ocarina and by doing
that I think I was trying to justify
using this medium at all I don't really
believe in like just God well I think
copying the instrument is dumb with
computers it's actually a principle that
my advisor Perry Cook has a copying an
instrument is dumb leveraging expert
technique is smart and so I was trying
to not just copy the Aqua me now trying
to make it expressive as possible but
then do one thing that again and this is
social dimension which allows you to
basically listen in on the world so let
me try to do a little demo that we
actually launched ocarina here and
assume in my network works
but Rose see I on the right network give
me a moment this is an ocarina that
needs you to basically say yes to stand
for visitor to say hey I iow ok there we
go what is that it's like some Harry
Potter going on here from someone
calling themselves peanut from the
middle of the u.s.
this one sydney
no name
[Music]
hi Europe Stockholm maybe oh yeah here a
lot of Zelda on the globe here a lot of
amazing grace on the globe amazing grace
is kind of like the stairway to heaven
of ocarina and that's the one that
everyone kind of like feel like they got
to learn because actually the first
tablet sure we put out when we launch
the app and and so if you actually you
can get a closer look at this
[Music]
oh shenandoah swirling music coming out
of the globe it's this is kind of I've
said this is an attempt to look really
hide the technology Zelda you can you
can't really go too far without this
tech you know on the globe without
hearing some Zelda and I think the idea
behind the globe was hey you know we
have technology that is always connected
to the Internet at least most the time
you have gps location but can we use
this to to do something you know a
little different do something that no
really instrument really can do and you
know you don't we know who these people
really are they just give themselves a
moniker but I think the idea is to just
give you that tiny bit of connection you
have with people out there Epona I
believe that's also on the name is
Zelda's horse that i'm not mistaken it's
a lot of stuff even they're not into
putting the beatles they're still
thinking about Zelda um
[Music]
yeah so this is a okay one more very
imperious of Alicia okay so um that's so
in some ways this is kind of an attempt
it's my social experiment it's one word
saying okay we kind of um allowed you to
have an instrument that while you're
playing like kind of make yourself
anonymously available to other people
also playing the instrument and that you
can just you know without knowing where
these feel large know there's someone
somewhere out there blowing into a phone
or denied me just just playing some
music and whether the plane something
like really recognizable or beautiful or
they're just noodling around and I think
we can all somehow identify with that
because we also have this thing in our
hands that holding like a sandwich and
blowing into to make some music so I
think that's you know that's all clean
that's really all of ocarina as it's an
artifact but I think in terms of artful
design if we break it down these are the
different axes that I think of like the
design is happening you know there was
definitely like some program software
design but really its exact size an
audio visual design is interaction
design it was designed really as an
expressive toy you know it's 10 maybe a
game you know it's a toy is something
that you without a lot of structure play
with unstructured playing games more
like there's some guilt and goals and so
I would say maybe the ocarina hero mode
is more like a game with you know you
gotta but then there's also just places
for you to just ruminate and in play it
was a product you know this is one of
the first products we put out its fuel
and in a time where it was great time
because I knew that nobody making apps
knew what the hell that we're doing so
it gave us it gave me this great sense
of like I can do no wrong because I can
do no right so I'm just gonna do it that
was good times and I hope I yeah I I
always feel like industries that don't
that never lose that actually
I tend to be the ones that continue to
really move forward I think once we feel
like oh we've stabilized and this is
that these are the trends and these are
how people should be doing if this is
the meta of the industry and it loses a
lot of it it's a bigger and I'm very
interested in industry set that don't
but also is kind of a social design so
I'll go through some of these first the
audio visuals on in design aesthetic I
think this was an example what I would
call an inside-out design you know this
is not was not an example of a top-down
process in terms of how this was
designed wasn't me like going I think
the world needs an ocarina on the phone
like something you blow into this is an
idea it was like it's like playing with
with hey we have this phone let's build
something and and you marry that with
some interest in some curiosity and and
the iphone fit the profile of like a 4
hold English pendant ocarina which is
about the same size same weight and the
level of complexity for the interaction
is also very similar there's you know on
the iphone 25 points multi-touch and the
four holes perfect as a microphone
because it's a phone and we have the
accelerometer which is something you
don't need to worry about usually with
aquamarine is but that's an extra thing
that we said we'll is there extra
bandwidth on the player that we can map
this just something meaningful and so
this inside-out design is trying to say
what working backwards from the medium
tinkering the medium working backwards
to see what fits and ocarina fits more
so than a guitar or piano drumset
harpsichord you know did end up
designing a piano and a guitar later on
but as a kind of a first instrument this
is one that tries to say well if we
designed something that could only
really work on the iphone and that took
advantage to the iphone what would it be
and this is this exercise emissive kind
of backwards top and bottom up design
and the mapping is quite simple it's
really just you know but i did the
aesthetic part of this is there were a
lot of these apps of coming out and I
think the way people are thinking about
abs and people still think about
that this is a mobile way to do X you
know and a lot of people took to like
naming their apps I this high calendar
you know I recipe book hi this I that
and all it is is at least thinking about
it aesthetically these are like mobile
versions of something else and those and
some of those are very useful in some
great apps but I think the way that I
want to think about this is I didn't
want this to be a facsimile of an
ocarina I wanted your phone I want you
to think and feel that the phone is the
ocarina and that's kind of that's
reflected I think in all aspects of the
interaction design and also the audio
visual design for example in the
interaction design it's breaks away from
this model where you're like flipping
through your phone like this you know
you reduced back to like eyes and in
this case a couple of fingers but here
you're holding the phone like a sandwich
and you're blown into it so I think it's
a very physical you know it's a very
physical design in that sense at the
same time I look at its design there's
just one of these like like I wanted to
make everything feel as organic as
possible and that's why as you saw in
the video things actually respond you
know with animation things light up when
you blow into it and everything is fluid
as I as I could have made and it's
coated up in OpenGL and i'm going to say
the interface looks something like this
and the circles gracefully expand when
you press on it and then and i wanted to
also combat this this idea that while
there is some very rough tactile feel of
okay the screen is pushing up against
you that's all it is that can never be
anything more than that but you at least
try to make fake people into thinking
you know that there is a little bit more
than that so by having the buttons
expand it feels like you're pressing on
an organic thing that response and it's
a visual way to kind of make up the fact
that the tactility beyond the touch
screen is really not there and so I
invest a lot of times into two things
you know you can see this there's one
there's some like unhealthy obsession
with circles there a lot of just count
the number of circles that are on this
and they're not just circles with their
layers of circles just a whole bunch of
like basically circle textures
additively blended together that moves
independently if
each other that throbs that light up in
response things even this ring this this
pink ring is a circle of circles that
lights up when you blow into it the year
this is just a subtle reference to Zelda
it's a triforce and but also it marks
where you're supposed to blow into the
phone so that's that's really that's
that and you know other visual design
roof I think I've made I started with
these textures like 15 years ago and i
was making like just random stuff with
him and i think i've been using these
those of you have taken classes for me a
karma will know how how often I've used
these things and how into a degree of
I've abused them but for example like a
bud in Ocarina it's really kind of these
layers of what I call flare is kind of
additively blended together and smooshed
and when you press on it you know some
layers contract and similars expand and
they glow and so this is kind of just a
subtle way of I don't know just making
up again for the lack of tactile
feedback from this but also it's
something to make really make the thing
feel alive I want you know I you know
later I've made magic piano which had a
mode where it's just a piano which it's
slowly breathing like it's just moving
it's kind of like it looks kind of like
a like a kind of disturbing actually it
looks like a bug or something that's
kind of just but I want to give this
illusion that these things are are very
are made of flesh and blood and you can
see the extreme close up and you clean
my fingernail there but extreme close up
of the what it looks like and can send
see everything's additively blended
together just to give that additional
like magic feel so that when they
actually coincide they have this extra
flaring effect and same on this side of
course this is just a lot more of the
same exact player is just much smaller
in different colors and I believe you
know this is kind of also that sounds
visual aesthetic it's very minimal I've
later use the same players to actually
make strings on the magic fiddle like if
you just have to stretch these out and
suddenly you have a line instead of a
circle so I've definitely got a mileage
out of these guys yes and in terms of
you know the other thing is I really
love spirals I love things that rotate
so this is a this is another kind of
this is actually as much an instruments
that is the piece we made for the laptop
Orchestra which is we're showing an
example this is not ocarina but this is
a you know the kind of kind of visual
thinking this is kind of what is the
thing as a piece called converge that uh
then my then grad student Juno and I
created for the laptop Orchestra and we
basically asked people to submit photos
of everyday life moments record some
sound of that moment and there's
geotagged I'm dying to send it to our
server and we basically collectie here
so this is like a really weird photo
album and it's weird because I can blow
it up so this is a photo album that's
more of a commentary on memory as it is
one that's keeping your photos and guess
what is doing its spiraling and well
let's see you can also bring back
memories this memories oh the joy and
light of a sunny day standing high on
the hillside above Golden Gate Bridge 81
kilometers from here and this is you can
look at a time six years 20 months
through 23 days for our seven minutes 41
42 43 44 this is also a really
depressing photo album that will forever
remind you that these everyday moments
are always receding in time from you you
will never be as close to these moments
as you are now because a second later it
will be that far much farther away so
it's in really effed up photo album
here's one from a little bit longer ago
intonation internations nation this
someone looks like rehearsing some flute
with a metronome somewhere within a
kilometer here maybe you had brawn
so and then you can go into the there's
like this vortex of images and let's
turn things into day let's make this
disappear a little let's wait until the
actually going to reform them it's just
so we can plow them up again the spiral
forms a little more quickly in that in
that case you can see the spiral forming
can add a little i'm going to zoom out
you can really see the spiral here and
i'm actually going to turn it in tonight
and the more zoom out it looks like the
galaxy like I said I really love spirals
I don't know they're just beautiful to
me and we can converse this into a
single point and blow it up again it's a
lot of fun see if spiral forming again
is actually truly a Bayes Kepler's laws
of at least the one which says you know
can this the rate of rotation is
somewhat proportion which is published
to the radius from the center of
rotation so you can kind of see that
this thing's don't rotate at the same
speed which is also very key for this
fluid organic feel to it things i would
definitely rotate much faster in the
center and let's go ahead and reform
this and this piece ends on a depressing
note to it basically just clumps up into
like this bowl and it'll go is in the
distance i don't know if that symbolizes
maybe some some kind of seems kind of
morbid to me but this is kind of the
ball of memory that life becomes at some
point so sorry about that anyway
um yes ok everyone is not like super
depressed that's where the spiral is
kind of you know I love spirals yes okay
ah on a more I don't know what kind of a
note the sound is made in Chuck it's
actually real time synthesized nothing
recorded in here and this is a language
that will bring you back to reality
because it's a language that will add
noise i'd like to say crash equally well
on all commodity operating systems that
allow you to make sound and yes question
it was pretty much well first of all the
symbol love is the chuck operator it's
like is my it's named after the verb to
chuck which means to kind of carelessly
throw one thing into another so this is
a kind of a metaphor for connecting
sound making modules but also for
passing data from things to other things
so it's a very left to right language
it's also what i call a strongly timed
language and has is very like
pathologically like imperative way of
thinking and programming time but also a
thought Chuck is a good name because it
sounds like like your friend you know we
are working on kind of code name project
Charles right now as a more nuanced a
more nuanced way to chuck but Chuck is
kind of like your friend even though he
crashes a lot so oh no should I should
okay I'll put out my list cool it's I'll
discover why you asked me back other
questions yes sure chief hello what's
joes what's Charles ah jack is working
on a way to Jack and I tell ya he's
working on a we actually do you want to
say it no
we are basically adding a layer of kind
of in the moment feedback and into Chuck
as your programming it we want to know
everything from what's working what's
not to emotional state jack is come up
with ideas such as like the WTF button
then can be used when things don't work
as you think they should we both use
this as a wake is kind of extreme
analytics but also as a way to get gage
people says I guess aesthetic and
interactive experience I have with Chuck
I wouldn't I want to you know I think
programming language is all about I
think for me it's all about making
people happy doing the things they got
to do so I in chuck was an attempt at
that I think I don't think it's there I
think it's like you know but we want to
know at least place woman as a friend
Chuck wants to know when when you're not
happy and when you're happy so that's
project Charles to be TB to be something
to be done TBD to be done this is the
for those you care about the signal
processing that's all it is is a sine
wave oscillating another triangle wave
as a vibrato that's getting basically
all moved by us a very intricate
envelope traded from filtering that the
input signal that's the microphone
instead it becomes the kind of
articulation and that goes through
another envelope and that goes to
reverberate around that's it so another
aspect of design is what I think it is
kind of reem utilized design and this
comes from kind of idea of laptop
Orchestra and I deal with REM utilize
design is the following you know the one
thing the computers allows us to do in
terms of making for example an
instrument is 2d couple things more than
we ever have traditional instruments
like a guitar ukulele you know the
sounding mechanism very much has to do
with how it sounds but also how you play
it those two things are fundamentally
somewhat inextricably coupled computers
allow us to say what is the input what's
the interaction with the output how do
you map them and the mapping and there's
no sound making cell making mechanism
can have nothing to do with the input
mechanism so this means i can make this
sound like cats the alchemy net if i
want instead of the sound of hearing so
that's a d couple thing however that's
not all just because we can doesn't mean
it's a good idea as with many things and
sometimes it's a good idea and other
times i think we also find ourselves oh
the instron so we build you know I think
you know I believe I believe I've bill
burr plank if I may it was here okay
Perry said that some of the instrument
he designed especially the kitchen where
where he's turned Cubs and tables and
instruments came out of question that
bill one's asked is that why isn't
anything I do in the computer mediated
space as satisfying what I do in the
kitchen um why isn't anything wasn't one
of the things I do in the computer
mediated space is interesting there's
nuances of satisfying as what I do in
the kitchen I don't know I don't know if
you can attest after having said that
okay great so it's a um I I think there
are certain things that about playing
computer music instruments that are if
that feels very weird it's it operates
KCAL per in a very different levels
depending on how physically you make
thing to how abstractly you make the
thing you know so I think the notion of
playing an instrument is fundamentally
different for for computers so and then
not surprising a lot of times we kind of
urine for that old sense of intimacy
that we want to have with our instrument
um and and we want to also feel like the
sound is really coming from the
instrument rather than from the computer
through you know the speakers around us
so in that sense you know this is kind
of an exercise in ream utilizing the
interaction with the sound into a single
object so ministers i'm not going to
read actually i will read this real
quick this is from the paper that
Rebecca fee bring Prairie and I authored
about kind of creating like physical
interfaces you know in and really what
this is about is chemically a design
ethos of taking whatever inputs and
sensors happen to be available and
thinking
raleigh's possible with interactive
affordances the ethos recognize that
physicality extreme convenience can
coexist and together a tremendous
positive effect on instrument building
composition performance and teaching for
the more taking further too familiar
input capabilities and co-opting them
and unfamiliar ways can imbue expressive
musical interactions the sense of
playfulness something we try to
cultivate much for music making and
teaching this was thinking about
designing instruments specifically for
the physical laptop and and so as an
example that here's another project
[Music]
laptop accordion with Sanjay and Aiden's
as if your moment of Zen
[Music]
Oh
so that's on Jane that that cool yeah
that uses the computer vision optical
flow basically tracking the rate at
which you're opening closing the lid
that's it and that's map in the same
similar way those articulations mapped
in Ocarina and this is kind of another
example mutual izing things but also
it's a gamble with free physical design
a precursor to a commune in terms of
design is also the sauna glider this app
is no longer available this is lost in
the antiquities of happen time but like
all this can be seen as a predecessor to
aquamarine Haven though it's not a
musical instrument for one just like all
Karina this is it makes no attempt to
add any kind of like embellishment to
like there's no skin to this lighter
just like there's no casing to the
ocarina and the whole idea is part of
the aesthetic that hey your phone is the
thing so here is the lighter that you
know it all has these functional
elements and and this of course a very
silly thing because it fails at doing
the one thing that lighters are supposed
to do it can never do that but else I
the social component that allows you to
at least see where other people around
the world have lit up and also
presumably spent a dollar buying a fake
lighter on their iPhone so that's a no
this is actually the video we made to
launch this product this is actually the
first smeal product
response to the touch again organic you
can actually light other phones even if
you can light anything else this is
actually done through sound and form a
very crude near field communication you
can blow it out so it already uses
microphone and then and of course we
have this like looks a turn to the
underscore that we really are a cult of
iphone users and you blow it out and
there's one more there's a they don't I
don't show here's if you rotate a half
way the flame singes the top your phone
resulting in smoke particles and a
really sickening singeing sound like
it's burning the side of your phone as I
say this flame is really inside your
phone so this is kind of again the this
is one of like probably dozens if not
hundreds of lighters I mean we weren't
the only one to say we just make a
lighter you know like many other people
have the same idea at the same time I
think we're the only one which the flame
can virtually burn your phone from the
inside and you can blow it out and
things like then you have a globe so
this is kind of a lighter that despite
its complete worthlessness as a lighter
isn't it is a design experiment in a lot
of other things two things like you know
a blog wonder of that was the most
northern most you've recorded iphone
user like that's in them that's middle
of nowhere it's inside the Arctic Circle
there's no visible landmass on any map
that will get fine there's six different
signatures six different phones out
there with sonic lighter who are they
are they signaling for help with our
phone and we don't know and the thing is
you don't really need to know to feel
that sense of connection in this kind of
social sphere we zoom in to Pasadena
we see that another user has left as an
emphatic unmistakable message meanness
the way to do this is you can of course
just walk down the street every few feet
blow it out and light up the thing again
and you're going to see how big this is
compared to like you know the football
stadium up there so maybe they're in a
car I don't know who is this it doesn't
matter somebody did this good job and by
the way it's in the earlier design
thinking in aesthetics we have we can
have this very crude way of thinking wow
what is how does how do our apps fall in
like we thought of two camps as one way
to think about this we can turn this
NASCAR versus NPR okay with the
assumption that these two represent
populations which are mostly like not
intersecting you know so I would say the
lighter probably perhaps is more NASCAR
not to say and people will listen to NPR
don't use lighters but i would say
ocarina is definitely like NPR I don't
you know and ask our I kind of steer
typically think like someone who's
hunting goes the Bigfoot like big like
Bigfoot truck rallies and go to WWF
wrestling and an NPR is like we sit
around and we think about all Karina's
and all day so I don't know no so this
is a this is kind of a crew admittedly
crude way to think about but you know
full disclosure here this is kind of how
how we were thinking of that and
actually ocarina when I first came in
store and became actually the number one
selling app for for like three weeks we
unseated an app called I hunt which was
squarely in the NASCAR to classification
to us and it was we those annex chose an
extra satisfying moment when we when was
like I don't know ocarina over or
hunting which I shouldn't I bring to
another bigger question of why why
ocarina certainly like it's been you
know I it's something that we did not
expect would be so we actually have such
resonance you know we built it because
it's seemed like fun thing to do but now
like
is like there's over something like 10
million users of ocarina and many of
them took to the internets and make
videos of themselves playing this and
this is basically like the marketing
departments dream of like when you have
users basically making marketing videos
for you and but also it underscored how
you know people did resonate with this
and I think has to do it again with this
this disarming fact that it's on a phone
like if I hand you violin and say be
creative with this if you play violin
they're like sure but if you don't like
me I'm like I don't know how to do that
but I'm like hey is it on my phone it's
kind of a game I can learn this sure and
it's kind of a it's kind of a good
icebreaker I guess you know so here's
one of our users this is why I love the
iphone sometimes people do things you
don't expect like blow into this phone
with your nose she turned out to be
alone like a lifelong knows flatus she's
playing knows fluid on a variety of
different types of flutes and this is
just the latest flute to be notified and
choose a one of the winners in our
ocarina video contest I think the
contest is like this blows ocarina
videocon des and we send her the prize
money a t-shirt and a box of Kleenex for
her troubles but I think this has to do
with kind of what Michael mention the
beginnings that a lot of this was an
attempt an experiment in designing
things to kind of bring music expression
back into into kind of more of casual
amateur setting you know if you think
about a hundred years ago before
household electricity and you married
that with this this well documented
truth that there's never been a
civilization on this planet that has
been without other music or dance so
music has always been with us but we
haven't always had computers mp3's radio
recording those all happened pretty much
in the last hundred years so some in the
other like thousands of years before is
how to electricity how to be
music will the logical answers people
made made it where it was hurt and heard
it where it was made so and also in fact
you know as well documented their
families played music is just a form of
entertainment and also at some point the
word amateur meant something really
positive and then you loved something
that's actually to break down the word
it actually means one who loves all
right so it's a more amateur it's a but
now of course you know we Eunice and
it's it within the context of amateur we
think of like to go like don't quit your
day job and don't don't do anything that
soon you have no expertise in you know
but I think there's something nice and
doing things that you have no expertise
and when you do it for things like
enriching you know and there's something
there's something is incredibly
enriching and joyful about making music
that is entirely different than
listening to it which is admittedly
wonderful and its own right but making
is it is it is as stiff as a joy of a
different different type so in some ways
I think and think of these kind of
instruments that expressive toys is a
way to kind of infiltrate the masses and
get people to play more music and I
think that's kind of a barometer of
success it's like I don't like I don't
need people to be playing this at the
next like you know Carnegie Hall a
concert people if you're playing this in
their dorms and living rooms I don't
know in line at Starbucks that's a win
because you know what people have been
made more music which my mind is like
that's just veg is better the world is
just a slightly better place because
people get there
there's another launch video we did sell
the one and we did stairway
[Music]
I'm very much into designing
anachronisms so this is like
this is you know if the lighter was a
cult this is kind of a hippie commune of
iphone users this is why we have this
rug that we're sitting on and this
crystal or that's in the middle here
check that out and then there's that's
mule it's a field marketing specialist
so yeah so we you know we kind of made
it try to make it as easy as possible
for people to actually just go and play
this thing and let's go through quickly
game design you know this in some ways
this is it's not really i think this is
an instrument before it's a game it's a
toy before it's a game but i think there
are game like elements in here and so i
think of this as gamification which is
really goes by a lot of other names
which i'll have time to go into brilli
it's kind of used a game design them
into non-game context and here the goal
is to get people to want to get better
and playing the instrument whether it's
pal kareena magic piano and whatnot so
and and so briefly i'll just mention
that you know what we deal with these
notions of playing versus gaming where
one is more freeform and unstructured
and improvisational and the other is
structured and i would say with ocarina
you know the design challenge is making
music making games that are expressive
games the potential to motive expressive
behavioral allowing for playful open
creativity in essence combining those
two concepts and the observation is that
musical instruments do appear more
specialized and then games what games
appear more that's easier and we can
probably harness things i think like
flow theory to help people lose
themselves in plane using and I think
games of nothing is it seems to me like
engineer to guy should bring about flow
that's kind of when it's implicit tacit
goals and also I think the point here is
that games don't have to come at the
expense of expressiveness I think you
can have both I'm a kind of like have
your cake and eat it too kind of guy all
right so have your game and
expressiveness too so design a lot of
other since ocarina would design a lot
of other music making games that range
from kind of in each of these have an
Intel an angle magic piano actually had
a duet mode that you can play with a
random person with like the most
atrocious latency possible and magic
fiddle had a story book that had
missions for you to go play the magic
fiddle for like your family a pet go
busking on the street with your magic
fiddle and report back it's kind of like
social homework
how can you to which direction introduce
the game mode leave trombone world stage
is a kind of a crowdsource thing or
basically had like people like play on
the world stage and then people serve as
kind of juries and kind of like a like a
panel kind of like the like American
Idol style and give you feedback on your
plane and it sounds awful and which is
part of the aesthetic I suppose so I'll
continue to you can you know Thea we try
to also think things in terms of the
musical aspects pitch this is user
control but the timing is open-ended and
user driven and the complexities
complexity is fairly multifaceted and
these were kind of three dimensions I
think of and think of designing games if
you look at magic piano the pitch is
actually not user control but kind of
baked in the timing is open still
complexity is much simpler so you can
kind of apply this way of organizing
kind of musical games and with other
things finally a social design this is
the full kind of this is the instrument
Walter actually this is a server with a
database that's actually housing mmm
operating of snippets which are
basically being captured as you played
as you're playing and they're a geotag
time tagged and there's getting served
back to you when you go to the globe all
right and within this is the idea the
technology should you know I like the
idea of technology creating calm i also
like this idea of technology
transcending the medium itself into
something that allows you to to make
more human connections and i absolutely
believe in trying to you know foreground
substance while hiding the technology
sometimes you know not knowing what the
mechanism is is is critical and here all
we want you to feel is that there's
someone somewhere out there it's this is
not possible without technology but this
you know hopefully is something that
that but that's you know technology
should not be the first thing people
think about when they come to the globe
you know that's that's that's the hope
and people do play on all kinds of
things and so in some ways the globe was
designed as this experience feeling
lonely and connect at the same time and
I won this idea you know feeling this
role bring this
this real human side too no matter how
small I think scale is not important I
think authenticity of the experience is
important so it's not trying to make
this earth-shattering like let's all
sing in create harmony even though
that's seems like a Worth where D cool
this is like there's someone someone out
there playing like final countdown from
from Korea who are they you know I think
that's in his own way calm and in my and
I think it is something of perhaps even
something sublime in that there is a
there's one quote that will leave you
with which came from the itunes really
you read it for you this is my peace on
earth i'm currently deployed in iraq and
hell on earth is an everyday occurrence
the few nights i may have off i'm deeply
engaged in this app the globe feature
that allows you hear everybody else in
the world planes most calming art I've
ever been introduced to it brings the
exact at the entire world together
without politics of war and just say
exact opposite of my life alright so in
deploy US soldier and this is like oh
wow you know we didn't expect us to see
this but this clearly he had it making a
human experience from reaction to this
which brings me then too I'm going to
end with in kind of this designing
opportunity kind of as his creative
process like I said design is post
rationalization I wish I could tell you
that you know I design Ocarina because i
want the world I wanted music for the
masses I want people everyday people to
play music and I want it to be like this
surreal like artistic experience oh no I
think I think I think for me like and I
think I think for any creative process
anything is one words just curious said
can I do this and I think that's
probably the overriding impetus for
designing ocarina and within that it's
like trying to do something that you
can't do anywhere else with this
technology like I said justify the
technology and to do it as beautiful as
possible whatever shades from that let
it let it be and you know kind of if the
medium is the message then let's craft
something with medium that has it has a
message
and so you know design ethos and
takeaways you know there's I think the
world is it you know for a while we
thought the world's going to go Vern
more more and more virtual and certainly
there's things in that direction but we
actually actually things are becoming
more fizzle are also becoming more
physical with research in AR drones but
also in simple things is just turning a
phone into a physical instrument again
high the technology for ground substance
and also this idea that you know
anything that's worth designing to me is
worth designing beautifully in striving
in search of something that is sublime
and I think that's that's true not only
from a beauty point of view but I think
practical problems when we design
solutions for them aesthetics is
arguably more important if not just as
important in those cases because at the
end the day we humans are not purely
functional utility rating creatures
would also also aesthetic once you know
and as much as you know Jackie once said
you know we have as human beings have
this urge to lean forward to all forever
hurdle ourselves into futures of
increasingly more advanced technology
unchecked by perhaps some collective
wisdom to like do so wisely right I
think that is true and you know I that's
not a very good outlook for like people
now because I think we're just going to
destroy ourselves before we know it in
this pursuit of this leaning in this
curiosity that is both good and maybe
not but at same time I think all is not
lost and to me it's like people also
respond to beauty to delight to kindness
much more so than they respond to the
opposite of these things and therein
lies kind of this practical purpose if
you will love art an artful design in
that it's it's your to balance that out
there's a there's you know it's an
intention way to make beauty but perhaps
a more tasks and unintentional purpose
actually soothing the savage beast if
you will so you know I know this is just
a like a flute on a phone but I think
you know I think it does definitely
makes me think that the things we design
whatever it is house no matter how
simple or how you know we're how simple
i think is worth doing so so anyway so
I'm writing about all this in this book
and it's coming out sometime and I want
to thank quite a few people certainly
those who may know everything from
laptop Orchestra to all the similar
products possible its meal karma and
also thank you all for listening so in a
globe feature that's needed populated
urban area to talk squint to be multiple
people like available to listen to right
and what exactly do you optimize for
here you could surface the guy who's
like the more experienced when we will
probably be playing something that's
more pleasant to listen to and therefore
a little boost user engagement hopefully
right but like I'm with what are the
things that you like take into
consideration about it's a good question
we do have a kind of a very crude
algorithm that if that figures out what
to serve up next in turn on the globe
and there's also their filters you can
apply then apply for you can apply
filter which says I want to hear things
that people have heart there's a heart
on hair you can just basically that's
like like and I only want to hear things
I've been like hard at a lot so that
typically will give you some fairly
skillful playing at the same time I
actually like the noodling I like
hearing people kind of like stumbling
over themselves playing this because I
do that too when I'm when I'm when I'm
practicing and I feel like I'm hearing
people and just like normal moments and
then there are people who like just I
don't know if the bug and in a server or
the rendering algorithm but it's just
like play these really really really
long notes and I had always think of
that is kind of like a very minimal free
jazz type of situation
I also have my mind is always
interpreting what I'm hearing and people
have listened to each other something
like 40 50 million times on the globe so
it's something that they do in people
are hearing said you know we sometimes
we we actually just have this on during
dinner like cool I've never I've never
done that that you know that's awesome
so but we don't really if the other part
of the algorithm tries to pin a
foreground maybe like newer content and
that's really it and there's nothing
more sophisticated and that we could do
more like kind of information retrieval
and try to serve a more interesting
content but I think luckily not quite by
design luckily the it's actually
interesting to listen to both and really
skillful people but also like because of
the casual nature this to just everyday
great question yes what would be your
philosophy of for example of my team
I've metin2 plan to sound like a device
versus augmenting the actual physical
goods or the actual physical musical
musical instrument with digital
functionality to make it do the things
that doesn't ah i'm i'm down for to do
both ah remember to put a philosophical
flag on in the ground we do do that has
a up their own things as well we kind of
augment thanks not always to great
success but sometimes i mean i think
some people some players actually have
additional bandwidth that they can apply
to other expressive things so you know
people have augmented everything from
trumpets to sit ours to tabla putting
sensor on them to make have them do
things that the church arrangement can
cannot cannot do and for me like i don't
i probably tend to more work more in the
in delay kind of design things out of
technology inspired by existing
instruments or kind of some whimsical
thing but occasionally i work with the
other thing a lot of my colleagues in
and students I shouldn't absolutely work
on kind of like augmenting existing
instruments so I'm not sure of answers
your question okay study but please come
on thanks so much for we're doing it
thank you
[Applause]